what's going on snyder cut
fans we're gonna watch two trailer
teasers
because we got an official and second
trailer for the snyder cut coming out
tomorrow so make sure to subscribe click
that notification bell so you get
notified when our reaction for that
trailer
is up but the two we got today you all
right breathing a little heavy are we
dark side so excited footage and uh the
bat tank today i didn't see the image of
this but i saw the hashtag
granny goodness trending and
i was like what is granny goodness
in this movie it was during when the
darkside one came out yesterday because
we missed it yesterday
so uh i'm assuming it's gotta be in
there somewhere
damn
wait a minute where's goodness we gotta
go frame by frame
damn hold on a second what where did she
go okay so you got flash running in
to the speed force oh that looks so good
there she is there she is
okay enlighten me okay so there's the
sod there's dark
oh he's got his omega beams
because when we saw the snyder cut
trailer before with the hallelujah song
that's when he was just ooxas so he
didn't have the omega beams yet but now
he's got the omega beats
awesome so steppenwolf is probably
definitely going to succeed
you know in awakening that would then so
i'm not like an expertise on i remember
watching superman the animated series
a family friend of ours growing up was
ed asner and he actually voiced granny
goodness
in the superman animated series so i was
very much
well aware of the sadistic lieutenant
that is granny goodness and then granny
goodness is also in the harley quinn
show she's in
like a whole bunch of medium too and
then yeah she's even in superman batman
apocalypse damn that's her right there
that's got to be her that's the only
grandma looking character right yeah
i mean you know grandma i mean she looks
like bran of tarth more than him
that's gotta be granny goodness and then
it's a dark side with the omega b
damn it's awesome it looks cool all
right let's watch uh
the bat tank one is what it was called
i definitely need to see this holy crap
it's cool you see that already
it's the first time i've ever caught
that is that the first time our violence
in some way
it's that f word maybe that's what
batman's wow
this is a big effing tank wow that looks
out of like the video game i know
it's so menacing and it does you know
look
that industrial style you know kind of
adhering to the more recent designs from
the batman it's
freaking massive i know it's way bigger
than a normal tank
that is a beautiful image that is a
beautiful image yeah and that definitely
looks like again you know something
ripped directly off of a comic book page
you know zack snyder loves that
oh my god that is absolutely gorgeous
yeah i'm in love with it
i hope this wasn't always yeah
wow if people were not convinced yet how
this is going to be so different i mean
the fact that you got
dark side to sod granny goodness
this massive looking bat tank during
this fiesta
that looks like it's out of the arkham
games yeah oh that is absolutely
beautiful
i wonder if that was in his original cut
or if this is one of those things
well no it's just curious and i hope
that we get to actually see it do some
badass action and not you know just be
like a little i just want to squeeze it
in
you know and this is wonder woman versus
steppenwolf right here
from the finale moments and then
anything else from the parademons
you see the pair of demons they kind of
just feel like silly goofy
not threatening henchmen in the
theatrical cut that came out really the
pair of demons they're
former warriors who were converted and
taken over by darkseid
so they have to be like threat like you
need a tank
yeah yeah you need the justice league
don't really get
that vibe with the other one
so no they're like putties and power
rangers exactly
exactly and then yes you get some ray
fisher in action here which i'm sure
walter hamada's very happy about when he
sees this trailer he requested that shot
being included
oh so much goodness so much granny
goodness that's master
what i'm wondering is i assume that that
moment with superman
with the laser blast i thought it would
be him versus steppenwolf but the fact
that he see darkseid in here and that he
is being kind of touted and and promoted
more
i don't know if that moment with the
omega beams is just after
the the you know going to the flashbacks
when he was just accessed and then
afterwards when he finally gains them
right
curious to see if we do actually see in
the finale
him fighting darkseid because it was
supposed to be a two-parter ending with
steppenwolf and then the second part
would be fighting darkseid i don't know
exactly all the additions or what he
decided to
shoot if he could conclude it that way
the commentary track is going to be very
it's
going to be insane but it's kind of
crazy how the past two weeks have been
building to weirdly not the release but
this trailer
i know like the trailer itself is the
event
like you got the blurred image of joker
first then you got two
clean shots of joker then you had
articles coming out of interviews with
him
and then you have uh these three
trailers to promote
the upcoming trailer which is really
gonna
seems like it's gonna be the heaviest
showcase for
this is not the theatrical cut at all
because
honestly there were a lot of people who
couldn't really tell the difference
uh i mean we could i definitely could
like undoubtedly
spend so much time talking about this
i've seen other trailer reactors who are
like i can't really tell what the
difference is other than a few things
but i feel like off of these trailer
teases alone you're like oh no no that's
in the
there's that's definitely not yeah
that's what all these images have been
oh yeah
because i think zack snyder composed the
other trailer that we got with the
hallelujah song
but he hasn't seen the theatrical cut i
don't know if he decided to like work
with someone else on this new trailer so
he could
be like let's make sure that people
really know for sure
this is not the same thing at all we
need to really demonstrate this is
wildly different so i'm kind of curious
to see
how much newer the newest footage this
is all going to be because some people
really
thought it was just like a few alternate
takes or some deleted scenes
i've seen some trailer reactions where
they couldn't tell the difference
well yeah maybe that's why with these
ones they're leading much more with like
let's
put dark side in the foreground and
let's put some other auxiliary
characters that were definitely not
featured last time so it does appear
like there's more
new like the plot will be different too
yeah all right guys well
make sure to subscribe click that
notification bell what do you think
about the bat
tank are you excited for granny goodness
to be in here last but not least
jt jt my man so listen i feel like every
month when we shout you out
there's some joke because of the fact
that like oh we're watching karate kid
you're japanese
let's shout you out oh we're watching
godzilla versus gong you're asian let's
shout you out on that because of the
asian [ __ ]
you're asian but snyder cut we're going
a different route this is no asian
characters
i hope you and walter hamada are good
friends
yes especially now now is that he needs
all the support he can get jt and a good
friend needs to be there and that's you
and uh i hope you're very much excited
for
raya in the last dragon coming up man
it's gonna be a damn good movie oh
all of your ancestors are involved with
it it's everything crazy to know how
hard you have worked to make sure your
influence is there but no in all
sincerity
um be as asian as possible as you watch
the snyder cut
and judge the martial arts choreography
for which i don't think you have a
background in it no he does
because he's asian that's not how you
yes
and i'm gonna go sign up for an improv
[Music]
class